Lawrence Krauss is a world-renowned
theoretical physicist a man who
significantly changed our view and our
understanding of the cosmos he's a
fierce advocate for the public
understanding of Science and aims to
bring it closer to the masses through
the origins podcast recently he's also
been pushing for much needed societal
and cultural changes Lawrence's books
have been pivotal in popularizing
science and have profoundly impacted me
since I first read them and his latest
book is no exception check out my
episode from earlier this year right
here join us as we embark on a
captivating Journey to the edge of
knowledge recorded live in October 2023
at the San Diego Aon Space Museum
Lawrence how are you doing it's great to
be here I I I'm I'm really thankful for
the museum and for Brian when when the
origins project decided to do some
events in California uh one the last one
we did was in Orange County a few days
ago and I contacted Brian I thought it'd
be great to come down here and Brian um
because he's on the board said you know
I have a great place and he arranged for
this to happen and and and so it's I
it's the first time I've been here but
it is truly an amazing place and what a
what a place to have this this joint
podcast in the sense that we're doing
the origins project is is uh does do
public events every now and then and
this is just a a wonderful venue so I
want to thank you and the museum it's
been it's been great and of course Andy
oron who who organized it and helped set
up the venue and and and and the the the
VIP reception it's been a it's been a
great chance to meet many of you so it's
fun to be with Brian here and and I hope
we'll disagree and in chat uh about
science and since it's his home turf I'm
going to turn it back to him for the
yeah one of the things I'm most excited
to talk to you about tonight uh in our
signature kind of way where we debate
things I am a what I call a practicing
agnostic Jew which we can get into what
actually that means la is a devout Bible
beading Christian as you all know can't
get enough of it uh we'll talk about
religion we'll talk about politics all
the stuff you're not supposed to but
really you SED science with a person
who's had an uh a considerable influence
both on my career in my thought process
but on a generation of of young young
people and I want to start with
something that you know you can deny
paternity maybe but um I want you to
talk about this mysterious substance
which I'm told fills the universe uh
almost without par and it's called Dark
Energy and it's something that you and
our friend mitell friend Mike Turner uh
really invented discovered let's talk
about the scientific process how do you
think of this creation and the fact that
it will someday rip all of our molecules
apart how did you no it won't it
probably won't do that but by the way I
appreciate when you say with the news
that you said I cast a long Shadow on
science because I thought that was
interesting way of putting it but um uh
so dark energy is the biggest mystery in
I think in fundamental physics it is the
fact that when you take
space and get rid of all the particles
and all the radiation and everything and
just have empty space there it weighs
something and and we don't know why it
is true that Mike and I had had proposed
um that it existed mostly I did anyway
and I think I convinced Mike that I I
was being
heretical uh
because
at the time the we looked at the data
and all the data of cosmology didn't
agree with the our picture of cosmology
the standard model of
cosmology we knew we theorists knew way
before The Observers and he's an
observer and I'm an experiment he's an
experimentalist I'm a theorist we'll get
into the difference and there are
differences um and but we theorists were
virtually certain that the Universe was
flat that that means it's that and I and
the other day in Orange County I don't
think I got to explain what flat was so
I should explain here it's not flat like
a pancake it's flat a flat universe is
just one in which the X Y and Z axes
point in the same direction throughout
all the space if you follow them up they
keep going in straight lines a curved
universe is one that you might imagine
the X Y and Z axis point here up there
but somewhere in the distant part of the
universe is over here over there and
over there and in a in a in say a closed
Universe if you look far enough in that
direction you'll see the back of your
head there are good theoretical reasons
and maybe we'll get to them why we
thought the universe was flat but but
there was a big problem The
Observers
being difficult people um did not wasn't
weren't finding the universe to be flat
they well they weren't flying enough
matter to make the universe flat because
the geometry of the universe depends
upon the stuff in it and you have to
have a certain amount of stuff to make a
flat universe and it wasn't the right
amount of stuff within a factor 3 and
then we looked at all sorts of other
observations and it wasn't just just not
agreeing and then we realized it in
order to make it all agree you'd have to
fill up the universe with another kind
of energy the energy of nothing and that
was so absurd and ridiculous that's why
I love the idea of proposing
it but more important I did it because
and this is really important because
we'll probably get to some current
issues at the Forefront of science
results are often wrong not because the
experiment Mentalist are doing they're
doing difficult work and it's very
difficult to measure things and
sometimes the first measurement is you
know isn't quite right and so I was
convinced some of the measurements were
wrong and this would be a a message for
observers to to to review their data and
and and get it right and and some of the
observers one I remember a guy named
Saul pruter said well you know we'll
prove you wrong and um and it turned out
more much to my surprise more than
anyone that that what we predict
predicted was exactly right that 70% of
the energy of the universe resides in
empty space we don't know where the
energy came from why it's there but it's
there and it's exactly the amount we
predicted and and those guys won the
Nobel Prize for the observation which is
fine because
uh no it is because the people who
convince the world of things are the
people who actually measure things you
know we can talk I can say it's flat but
or I can say there's Dark Energy but no
one's going to believe it unless The
Observers in some way
confirm that and so physics is an
empirical science it's an experimental
science and and and it's led by
experimentalists I say that as a
theorist um but any case so it turned
out to be right and and I was very
surprised but but we don't know if it's
constant if it's going to stay there
Brian said it's going to tear us apart
only see if the dark energy is there one
of two things can happen it could just
stay there which is my bet by the way to
stay there not change and then it would
be something that's akin to something
Einstein invented called the
cosmological constant a fundamental
lowest energy state of the
universe or it could get it could go
away one day and we talk about how
that's happened earlier in the history
of the universe something very much like
it or it could increase now if it
increases then dark energy has this
weird property that it's gravitationally
repulsive all of you who studied physics
know that gravity sucks okay it always
pulls pulls in if you put energy in
empty space it
blows okay and it causes the expansion
Universe to to accelerate and that's
what The
Observers Saul and others looking at
Supernova I first measured but if it's
constant it causes the universe to
accelerate but it really only impacts on
the evolution of the Universe on the
largest scales that's why we never
observed it before you have to look at
the motion of distant galaxies but if
it's in increasing its effect becomes
more and more important on smaller and
smaller scales so right now it's pulling
apart galaxies the galaxies aren't being
pulled apart there our galaxy is the
same size and it's not growing due to
even due to the expansion of the
universe but if the dark energy
increases eventually that repulsive
force will blow apart the Galaxy and
then if it keeps increasing it'll it'll
blow apart the solar system and then
it'll blow apart planets and then it'll
eventually blow apart atoms and it
eventually will blow apart space itself
it's called the Big Rip a call a former
student you know invented the name it's
a nice name I think there's no I would
say there's no theoretical reason to
expect that at all there's no theory
that suggests that that dark energy will
increase it's a be it's a cute thing
that the you know captured a lot of
people's imagination but it's not likely
the likelihood is it that it's staying
the same or quite possibly it may not be
a fundamental energy of empty space it
there may be somehow being energy being
stored in empty space and it may go away
and that would change everything
including our well including life so
anyway that's a long answer this won't
happen for several billion or perhaps
trillion years or so keep paying your
tax well actually show up tomorrow now
interesting thing is we don't know
because we don't understand it it could
happen tomorrow the great thing about it
is if it h we won't know it until we
won't know it till it hits us and we
won't be there afterwards the effect
will happen at the speed of light and so
we will be go away and before we even
knew we got hit so it doesn't matter
enjoy life have a you know add that's
like that song says night sorry to
interrupt a regularly scheduled program
but before we dive deeper into the
mysteries of the cosmos with my
wonderful guest Lawrence Krauss I have
something incredible to share with you
so many people who have a deep desire to
learn about the cosmos get discouraged
when they try to decipher the language
of the universe when they all of a
sudden find themselves swimming in a sea
of data now now it's true cosmology is a
datadriven science that relies heavily
on computation which can be very
intimidating and that's why I love
brilliant an intuitive and Hands-On
platform for interactively learning data
science mathematics and computer science
it's designed specifically for
bite-sized learning and offers a low
press environment where anyone can
flourish and develop new skills whether
you want to finish some basic courses or
dive deep into advanced topics such as
AI astrophysics group Theory and data
analysis there's something for everyone
in fact their computer science
fundamentals course is your ticket for
mastering computational problem solving
and algorithmic thinking skills that are
essential for unlocking the secrets of
the cosmos and the best part brilliant
tailor your content to align with your
learning needs allowing you to progress
at your own pace this is hands down the
best way to learn these types of
subjects and Brilliant does it all in a
delight full package that I love to use
every day on my phone or even on the
computer and if you want to try
everything that brilliant has to offer
for free for a full 30 days just visit
brilliant.org
drbryan keing or click on the link below
in the description the first 200 of you
will get 20% off of brilliant's annual
premium subscription now let's get back
to the universe when you think about the
differences between observers
experimentalists theorist is I I find
like a lot of my students don't really
comprehend the subtleties between those
but I I think one thing is you know
right over there they put up a great
image of Earth's nearest neighbor the
moon and that's a view that Humanity
never had for thousands of years until
some Dutch guy took his spectacles and
broke them in two and put one in front
of the other and then Galileo are my
hero at least I'm sure you're also to
him for intellectual debt he turned it
to the moon and no one had ever done
that before never looked up with a
telescope until Galileo essentially they
were looking in people's windows before
that yeah that's right anyway yeah I
mean my neighbor was quite quite
attractive anyway looking at the moon
even now you can see it you can use
something built by a human being you can
observe something then you can take that
observation and use it to test a
hypothesis one hypothesis that Galileo
tested was whether or not that ball was
actually perfectly smooth and
crystalline and ideal in its form and
when he saw it wasn't that it had
mountains and it had valleys and it had
holes in it and all sorts of crazy stuff
he could use that to formulate a
hypothesis and he said famously I love
this quote he said a scientist should
measure what is measurable and then make
measurable what is not yet so I've
always been curious what do you think is
the minimum amount of knowledge uh that
a an educated lay person and some of you
are brilliant lay people but what do you
think an educated lay person should know
about science and two what should a
theoretician like those that you train
no versus say an experimentalist such as
someone in my laboratory building
telescopes now let let me let me preface
this by saying physics being the most
advanced of the Sciences in some ways is
probably is is one of the is not the
only science but one of the only
Sciences where where it's so complicated
in there's so much intellectual baggage
that it has in most areas of physics
separated into theorists and
experimentalists because what you need
to do to be a good experimentalist in
terms of The Cutting Edge technology
that you have to master requires a great
deal of time and simly the mathematical
baggage that you need to to understand
fundamental science and physics is also
extreme so you don't see theorists and
experimentals the
last in my opinion the last great
theorist experimentalist was enrio fairy
who who at University of Chicago if you
saw if you saw that movie uh up himer
you would have seen fairy he's a huge
hero of mine um and he he was he was a
theorist in fact U um and and and an
experimentalist heally well and he he um
he proposed the fundamental Theory one
of the fundamental theories that later
ended up describing one of the forces of
nature and then did the experiments on
it and won the Nobel Prize I think for
his experiments but um anyway it that
was the last time you could sort of do
that so it's sort of separated in terms
of the the
fundamental stuff that people should
know I really think that what we really
need to teach is not the stuff that you
should know but the process by which you
know it and that's the one thing that I
think is most important for people to
carry on you know the details of science
are fascinating for me and you and I
think for most people once they realize
it's science you know a lot of people
don't realize they're interested in
science because they don't know it's
science that's one of the reason I wrote
The Star Trek book okay CU you know I go
to a party and say I'm a physicist and
they go how about those Yanke or
something and then uh and then I'd say
you know talk about time travel or warp
drive and and people are fascinated but
so that's great and this and and it
really is amazing and I guess people
should of course the basic things people
should understand about the world is
that there was a big bang the universe
is expanding Evolution happened basic
stuff like that but more important the
process by which we get that information
the process by which we test it because
that's the tool those are the tools that
people will carry with them in all of
the areas aspects of life and if we just
used the scientific method then politics
and well even religion but politics
would be would be more sensible and more
rational because people would test the
ideas of politicians and I say are they
telling the truth but politicians might
also develop policies based on empirical
evidence and and also be able to change
their minds do a policy it's not working
we're going to change our minds wouldn't
that be wonderful so I think that's the
kind of thing that that we really need
to teach I wish um as a as a theorist
I've of course come to appreciate
experimentalists much more than I did
when I was a a a student theorists you
know like Oppenheimer right it it's the
sexy stuff it's Einstein and everyone so
so somehow theorists have captured
people's imaginations and the the
tinkerers if you wish aren't usually the
heroes of the movies but they're the
heroes of Science and I kind of wish i'
i' I as a student appreciated that I
more I actually did a degree in
mathematics and a degree in physics and
I did that for a variety of reasons but
one of the reasons was so I could get
out of the laboratory
requirement in physics okay and so but
but over time of course I've come to
appreciate that and and as a theorist
actually I used to be a very
mathematical theorist when I was a
student a graduate student and then a
friend of mine who you know Sheldon
glasa who won the Nobel Prize I remember
when I was a student he once said to me
there's formalism and there's physics
and you have to know the difference and
and from that time on I've always in my
physics tried to tie it to things you
can measure and see and that's become
fundamental to me and to try and
understand what observers can do and
experimentalists can do and I in my life
I tried to propose new experiments
because it's fascinating to learn about
new technologies because every time we
open a new window on the universe we're
so I think I think if people realize the
significance of that that would be very
important but it's not the facts it's
that it's the process it's the tools and
I do think everyone should the problem
with you know this when if you're in a
physics lab it's just like first year
physics is boring in all anyways thing
it's things sliding down inclined planes
it's uh but experimentally it's also
these recipe things you know here's the
stuff and you do this and it's not it
would be great if we could design
experiments that people could discover
not not know what the answer was going
to be discover because that's really
when you're playing that's what's really
really fun I have a special favor to ask
you YouTube analytics tells me that of
the 30,000 plus of you that viewed my
previous chat with Lawrence for his book
The Edge of knowledge only 13d of the
viewers actually subscribe to the
channel I'd really appreciate it if you
consider subscribing to this channel
doing so helps me get great guests and
helps me deliver the the great content
that you've come to expect from this
channel thanks so much for helping me
help you now back to my live chat with
Lawrence kuss but I think you know
sometime you'll hate this phae Lawrence
I know but I think we should teach the
controversy and by that I don't mean
what you're thinking about but I mean
you just mentioned this boring rolling
down inclined plane well you know who
came up with the formalism for that it's
my hero we already mentioned him Galileo
yeah it was his final book He was
discussing relativity He was discussing
how things in relative motion cannot
determine who is truly moving and who is
stationary if you're a fish in the ocean
next to a boat and the boat has an
aquarium on it and there's a twin fish
of yours and they're swimming you cannot
tell relative motion who is moving he
also used a genius trick by using this
incline plane that we call it to slow
the force of gravity back then they
didn't have clocks you couldn't measure
things you had your pulse you had an
hourglass you use this pulse and I you
know you have you been to Florence have
you I've been I not only been to I had a
I had a conference hosted a conference
in his prison house and that's the
controversy because I want to say no but
anyway I like that I like the museum
there the science everyone goes to the
art museum in Florence but go to the
Museum of Science in Florence they have
inclin plane there the little telescope
which you just can see how he and I
think they have his finger uh that's in
a different Museum but yes it's his
middle middle finger I was about to do
it but I won't do it uh just to that
plane making noise overhead but what I
want to say is imagine you taught people
this that Galileo's manuscript was
smuggled out under penalty of death that
that manuscript that we talk about if we
told that to freshmen and yeah and
sophomores when we teach the first year
students I think it would make it more
engaging I think we do a terrible job
we've been given the greatest script
ever made I mean The Greatest Story Ever
Told is your book right but the greatest
script ever handed or bestowed upon
humanity is the story of Science and we
are the worst actors on any stage
imaginable I feel we need to do a better
job I think you speak for yourself no
I'm just joking but um the uh well
everything I know no actually I agree
with you I actually require my students
especially the non-science students to
read Galo I always you know would
photocopy because he doesn't have the
copyright anymore anyway i' I'd
photocopy parts of the book and um and I
because it read I've I've often said
this it's we force these students to
read like James Joyce but Galileo is
easier to read and funnier and and
poetic and so I I really uh I I'm a huge
fan of galileos and and I I do think
it'd be great for students to read
Because you see how these things which
see as you say seem boring now how how
he was thinking and and seeing the
thought processes what I think people he
was wrong too he great scientists great
women great men make great mistakes
brilliant blunders right yeah yeah no no
so it's uh but you're absolutely right
the reason we do incline Plaines is
because it's too hard to when you drop
something it travels it accelerates so
fast that's why Aristotle thought you
know things immediately their final
velocity and he said well if I do it on
a climb plane things will it'll slow
things down but I can watch them
accelerate and and um and it was the
basis of modern science and and uh and
yeah he's he's he's at the top for I
wonder if there will be new not only new
teachers for for upcoming students but
but new new students and new and new
ways of thinking and I'm thinking
particularly of of large language models
of artificial intelligence you talk
about this in your latest book The Edge
of knowledge hold it up so people can go
to Amazon you know when they're not
getting my book yeah yeah I know you
your book is there somewhere you hold up
your book in a second we'll get there
and and that is artificial intelligence
and I wonder I I wonder how how you
react to this statement when I uh think
of what G what Einstein who was a
successor to Galileo in many many ways
uh not like that prick Newton who you've
written about as a as a real jur and I
learned that uh from your writing but
good old Albert uh he said that he had
his happiest experience his happiest
thought ever was that somebody in freef
Fall Would experience no gravitational
force and that led him to construct the
Einstein equivalence principle and
everything in gr follows from that but
you know what people don't realize is
that he said that but he said that the
only time his heart ever had
palpitations and this is what's
important I mean they think Einstein was
sort of working this vacuum they all
think you know the is are alone at night
just coming up with things but he was
tied to observation and experiment and
and the moment that he wrote down this
beautiful Theory but that didn't give
him palpitations even though it was
beautiful and he once said if he he knew
it could be wrong because it was so
beautiful but although most theorist say
that about their own work and most of
them are wrong but um but he said when
when he did the calculation for general
relativity and discovered something
called the parhelion of mercury
Mercury's orbit sort of rotates very
slowly few seconds of Arc per century
but it would no one could understand it
Newton's Laws didn't give it and he did
the calculation general relativity and
it came up with the exact number that
people had observed that's when he said
he had heart palpitations and almost
fainted that's it was realizing that he
he you know it agreed with observation
and that so physics isn't done in this
vacuum it depends on the observations of
the time very very rarely theorist lead
but but uh uh you know even Einstein
wasn't was certainly a product of his St
and his his earlier Theory special
relativity people I hate the way it's
taught in schools and and I written in
my books of different ways of teaching
it everyone says okay the speed of light
is a constant in fact I got asked by
someone the other day Orange County what
if you know what if what if we find the
speed of light isn't constant or
something he didn't just say oh the
speed of light is constant and therefore
the world is crazy what he realized was
two things in fact it's good you
mentioned Gallo Galileo told us just
what you just said Galilean relativity
if you're on plane and the windows are
closed and you throw up a ball you don't
know you're moving we don't know we
think we're standing still but we're
moving at 30 km per second around the
sun we feel like we're standing still
because Galileo told us there's no
experiment you can do that will tell if
you're moving or standing still if
you're moving in a constant velocity or
standing still I say you're moving you
say I'm moving it doesn't matter that's
Galilean relativity it's true it's been
tested James Clerk Maxwell developed
electromagnetism this theory of
electromagnetism and for reasons I won't
go into right now but I could but I'm
not going to it turns out the theory of
electromagnetism is a be is our
prototypical most beautiful Theory we
have in physics
almost it was inconsistent with Galileo
you couldn't have Maxwell and Galileo at
the same time and it was thinking about
that that forced him to the theory of
relativity the only way to make Galileo
and Maxwell consistent was to do crazy
things to space and time so he was
driven to it by thinking about the
observations time so if if max if
Einstein had been born you know Maxwell
was like 50 years before Einstein if if
he'd been born 80 years earlier he
wouldn't have been Einstein one of my
favorite anecdotes about Einstein is
that he was offered the presidency of
Israel and can you imagine what kind of
a career he could have had if he was the
president of Israel he could have been
famous uh but I I I wanted to make one
point about this and get your reaction
to it so here's Einstein he's saying
you're freef fall you can't feel this
gravitational force that you're in
motion and it was this delightful
viseral experience that he had how can
my iPhone running chat GPT as it often
is how can it experience heart
palpitations how can it have a happiest
thought how can it visualize the
sensation of Freefall what I'm getting
at can we have and I asked this of your
friend n Chomsky when he was up you know
can you have creativity of a physical
variety that without embodiment well no
in fact again I was talking about this
the other day I I think it's quite
likely and I talk about in the new book
I I think it's quite likely that that
systems AI systems if they ever could be
self-aware and conscious will not be
able to do it unless they have feelings
and feelings will require uh sensors
that can sense the outside world and the
internal state of the system that's what
what's developed in us the homeostatic
system we can started sensing pain and
pleasure but beyond that we we sense the
world and then those physical feelings
turned into emotional feelings and I
think it's quite likely that you won't
see a a chat GPT or a static
regurgitation system that can't sense
the world now can you sense the world
through the internet maybe at some level
but U but I do think that that that
Consciousness that self-awareness
requires that that that connection to
the world the interesting question is
whether it'll become an emotional
connection or not and and who who knows
because you have emotions without
visceral you know without sensors or
replication of physical sensation can
have what can you have emotions or
emotions CH between one or the other
emotions or visceral Sensations what
would you you know who knows I mean it's
we do know that amibas don't have you
know don't feel good or bad but as I was
saying I I I debate this you know with
some
neuroscientists my dog and I was just
actually tonight there's a podcast
dropping with Robert sabulski on our
podcast from his new book about Free
Will um and and sabulski agrees with me
our dogs you know have emotions and feel
bad and good I'm convinced of it and and
not just Levi but I'm not sure my cat
does but my dog well who knows what cats
are thinking they cats are cats are are
are yeah you can't tell what cats are
thinking so what if you were a beginning
graduate student right now or smart
undergraduate there's some here tonight
and there's even some you know freshman
over there talk there the youngster the
future is right there what what excites
you about science nowadays you were
starting off you somebody asked you what
would you do a 20-year-old is started
getting into science brilliant smart
whatever has the gifts privilege
whatever what do you advise them to do
well you know the of course I should i'
advise them to do what they like to do
which is the first thing because they're
not going to be good at TI unless enjoy
it but but one things that I one of the
things I would tell them to think about
which I un un fortunately well I did
what I did but when I was growing up I
my mother wanted me to be a doctor of
course and I thought I was going to be a
doctor and I took biology in high school
and I dropped it after two weeks because
we dissected frogs and memorize the
parts of frogs wait wait a second Jewish
mother wanted you to be a doctor not
only she wanted me to be a doctor I
think I've told this story when I got my
first job at Harvard which was the best
job in the country at the time um um my
mother phoned up my my first wife at the
time that day when I was out of there
and said he can still become a doctor I
was
late and uh anyway she was PR for a long
time but um anyway so I went into
biology class and I was memorizing the
parts of a frog and I hate me I the
reason I like physics is you don't have
to memorize anything in principle and
and so I I I feel cheated in a way
because of course DNA had been
discovered you know I was a child of
this at that age in the 60s and DNA had
been discovered a decade earlier but of
course in high school it usually takes
20 to 30 years to get into the books and
I didn't realize what an incredibly
exciting field it is so nowaday in fact
when I when I was doing my PhD I did an
MIT as one does I think and as one I
hope one does I got discouraged many
times I think students should get
discouraged if they're not getting
discouraged then they're not really
pushing the edge of the envelope and I
thought doing and my mother would have
been thrilled I thought of doing a joint
mdphd which you could do at Harvard MIT
and so I went to uh the the cousin of a
friend of mine who was a chair of Cell
Biology I wanted I was going to do
biophysics you know I like fundamental
physics but I was getting so discouraged
so I went to see him and this was in
1980 81 maybe late 70s early 80s and and
I said to him you know should I do this
and he said don't do
biophysics and I said why and he said
because it's not a interest to
biologists and it's not of interest to
physicists that was true in 1979 but now
it's really one of the most exciting
Forefront areas of physics because
biology is becoming an area where
physicists are learning to study
physical processes and of course the
tools of physics are being used in
biology so it's an incredibly exciting
area so I would not I would say you know
and of course genetics and genomics and
combinatorics and genetics and along
with AI incredibly exciting area and and
the disciplines of the 19th century
disciplines are dis appearing so the
interface between physics and biology is
disappearing and and so I would argue
that there's a whole Spectrum from
biology to fundamental physics and in in
the kind of physics that if you ask me
what are the sort of growth areas one is
manipulating Quantum systems we can
manipulate Quantum systems like we could
never do before some of it involves
quantum computers some of it involves
making new materials that might do just
what you wanted to do um of course
astrophysics is a and cosmology our
growth theories because we have all
these new tools ultimately though I
think what you know I would come back
and say what well I would say try a
bunch of things when students ask me
where they should go to graduate school
I often say go to a school that has a
lot of different programs so you can see
what you might like and it's so I often
say it's more important who you work
with than what you work on because your
adviser and you develop a tight
relationship since we're in the Aon
Space Museum the best one in the world
uh I want to uh run a topic by you there
something called the V Carman line which
is Loosely defined people are here more
expert than me but it's Loosely defined
as a boundary between space and and the
Earth's atmosphere and it seems to me
that you know kind of the the most
pressing problems that that are uh being
approached by physicists and you worked
on some of these all happen below the
Von Caren line and I'm talking about
nuclear war I'm talking about uh
pandemics that spread through
atmospheric transmission and uh and
climate change and climate change
so you've written books on at least two
of the three of these things I a wait
your biophysics book which is
undoubtedly being worked on as we speak
but but of these things can you rank
them as this what you were I should say
the the uh chairman of the board of
atomic science of the bolon of atomic
scientist which is one of the foremost
agencies founded
Byer and Einstein so I was very honored
to have the the same position as them
yeah what keeps you up at night I mean I
often say you know the problem with
physics is that we saved the world you
know we we created the atomic bomb but
that that's been that's not clear of it
Einstein deeply regretted it Oppenheimer
had some regrets not really clear
exactly what he regretted uh you and
Shelley glasow written about this
pandemics science has made the world a
better place to deny that I think is
ridiculous people in this audience are
alive who would not be alive to be here
a 100 years ago for word for Science and
more people eat and are are are able to
survive and live a higher quality of
life because of science we can do
amazing things we can communicate around
the world we can we can experience
things we could never experience someone
with a with a phone in even a poor
Village in in Africa experienced parts
of the world they never could experience
before where most people in the world
never for most of human history never
walked more than 10 kilometers from
where they lived yeah and of course
along with technology can come problems
and how we address that is is
unfortunately not a scientific question
it's a political question so the
politics of dealing with these questions
is much harder than the scientific ones
the Technologies of dealing with climate
change are much easier to consider than
the politics of implementing it I never
rank things um and and all of those
things
um concern me I think nuclear war is
still in my mind the the the most
immediate and and it it gets poor well
maybe now it's not but it it it amazes
me that people sort of um as you know I
or may know you know I I wrote I written
for lots of newspapers over the years
and every time I wrote an article about
nuclear war or nuclear
weapons it had the least response of any
of any of the pieces I wrote I think
people don't want to think about it but
people don't realize that there are it
right now A thou at least a thousand
Warheads in the United States and Russia
that are on trigger hair alert but ready
to be launched if a perceived signal of
another launch is perceived and and and
that also as people did learn when when
that guy was President a few years ago
the command and control infrastructure
of this country is such the only person
who can issue a launch
for order to launch in glob because is
the president and no other Organization
no it doesn't have to go by anyone else
there's no other individual who can who
can override that unless they decide the
president's crazy but in the actual
organization there's no there's no uh
you know no other people don't going say
hold on so I do think it's amazing as
it's amazing that we've been around for
70 some odd years without the use of
nuclear weapons and maybe mutually
assured destruction is is part of the
reason but it's a it's a problem and
it's a problem we could address but it's
a political problem but you know saying
that scientists create the problem you
know Steve Pinker had a great
analogy he said it's like it's like
blaming Architects for doal you know you
had to have Architects to design the
concentration camps is is is are
concentration camps a necessary product
of architecture no and so I think I
think it's really you have to think
about it carefully before you point
those fingers before I want to ask you a
question though for a second you you
asked me um what people should know what
do you think people should what as an
experimentalist do you think people
should you know what do you think people
should know in in in and when in science
in school well I mean I think for me the
most important things that that people
should have as a scientist first of all
and I'll speak to that first is humility
but I don't think you can only have
humility I think you need a little bit
of I call it Swagger maybe it's
arrogance that you can actually attempt
to take on problems that even Einstein
was unable to solve and hopefully you
know maybe even people in this room can
approach and solve it it's not an
exclusive sect of a high priesthood that
can't be approached except by the Ord
members of a certain sect but I also
think that we should also not fool
ourselves we're mostly wrong I mean it's
amazing how much we've been able to do
you know to come in in a few decades to
you know from the first transistor if
you look at the first transistor in bed
in 1956 the first practical transistor
shley Bine Etc uh it looks like uh the
following say go and get some Bazooka
Bubble Gum chew it up and go down to the
dry cleaner and get a wire hanger and
stick it together on a piece of rock and
that's exactly what it looks like yeah
and now each and every one of you has 14
billion of them in your pocket right now
except for maybe the kids but maybe you
know maybe they even do now don't let my
kids they know how to use it better than
you do actually that's right when I I
first got worried about technology when
one of my kids was looking at me and I
was just staring into her beautiful eyes
there only a three-year-old could could
have this perfect innocent face and and
then she reached up to touch me and I
was welling up the tears and then and
then she tried to swipe and and you
change that change my image um but but I
think that we should know that you know
you need to be we need to be humble
we're often wrong uh but the progress
gets made you know exponentially and we
just are not capable of thinking with
our L linear limited brains of the pace
of change and I think that is the
hardest thing I think scientists the
public should know that a good scientist
should often say as your tutor as your
Mentor Richard fan said you know science
is the belief in the ignorance of
experts not the knowledge not the wisdom
but the ignorance that actually Lawrence
wouldn't have been able to create this
concept of dark energy had someone got
to it first or been right that there
actually is no such thing as dark energy
so you doubted that person it was
Einstein at one point and you Prov that
wrong or you conjecture that he indeed
may be wrong and I think that's
incredibly powerful that you have to
realize science is done by people and
human beings despite the contrary right
yeah and you know the first I said it
the other day the first three words in
the book are the most important words in
science or I don't know they but but
actually what we really should get
across you made a good point most ideas
are wrong most experiments are wrong
when they're first done and that's okay
the Press never gets that I I was
castigating the press the the other day
not because they all you know someone
gets an absurd result and their
University do press office sends it out
and and then simply because most papers
don't have enough money to have science
reporters anymore the science reporters
just take the press release and publish
it and it's nonsense and you read it as
a scientist and you know it's nonsense
and then and then it's wrong but no one
ever writes that story later on they
just show another result that is agrees
with it and it gives people the idea
that science is is fattish if you
weren't wrong most of the time anyone
could do science I mean that's and it's
a process can do science right I mean it
shouldn't be this exclusive thing that's
only populate by Einstein and doesn't
mean that you guys I'll go out there you
know Einstein says a lot of things right
one of the things he says was
imagination is more important than
knowledge but you know I don't know
about you when I go to my you know
gastroenterologist I don't want to say
I'm going to try this new procedure I've
been waiting to try would you mind if I
imaginated on no but but I do think it's
it is important to have uh we don't want
people mistake this they they everybody
have you heard famously uh Eisenhower's
farewell address where he warned about
the dangers of a what did he talk about
he talked about military industrial
military industrial complex that very
same farewell speech he warned about the
dangers of a technological scientific
Elite that would do things to promote
their own interest and keep it shield
and I often say that you and I as every
scientist who's paid by the public has a
moral obligation to share what he or she
does not to be professional
communicators like you know Neil degrass
Tyson or you know mitcho Kaku or whoever
you like uh Jan 11 or somebody but but
but should
give back to some proportion what they
received from the public you know look I
I've spent a lot of my life explaining
science and I and I and I enjoy doing it
and I actually think what Young SC
because the young people who want to do
what I'm doing say say how how do how
can I do what you're doing and I always
say to them do good science if you're a
young scientist and you're a good
scientist what you should do is spend
your time on science now if you're
interested in reaching the public and
explaining things the more s you do the
better more opportunities you'll have to
then reach out but but I think most
scientists actually do want to but feel
uncomfortable it's very the first time
you you talk out Academia is a very safe
environment people that pretend it isn't
but it is it's an ultimately self en
it's safest environment and so when you
go out in the public it can be
terrifying and I understand that and so
I don't think everyone should be in fact
I remember when the National Science
Foundation once had some requirement I
when I was chair of case where you went
um young faculty have come in they get
apply for these awards from the National
Science Foundation and they' they'd have
to have a part of their plan which was
an Outreach plan now I'm a big believer
in Outreach but this was nonsense
because these got people were post talks
they'd never been involved in Outreach
they they were really interested in
doing their work and they'd come up with
these cockamamy plans none of which ever
happened and and I think forcing them to
do that is crazy they there are people
who are talented at it and naturally
like to do it like anything else and
will do a good job but there most there
are many of my colleagues I would far
prefer not have a the public would be
better off if they didn't hear them so
we talked about a lot of things uh a few
more minutes the two of us can chat
about um prerequisite for most podcasts
talk about I but also talk about
something that has those two letters Ai
and that's aliens I haven't talked to
you about this very much I'm going to do
I'm going to do an event in New York on
on December 1st not debating because I
stopped debating UFO people but I'm
having a dialogue with a guy named Nick
Pope who's uh who was the MI6 in British
guy who had who looked at Nick looked at
yeah he looked at unidentified objects
and
so X Files or something anyway what was
that I think he was an inspiration
allegedly for somebody in the X Files a
Moulder or Scully I I may mold SC I hope
it was hope it was Scully and not molder
but anyway well let's talk about that so
so one thing that's always amused Me
Maybe is the fact that the Public's
Fascination did sort of start to you
know initiate around the time of the
atomic bomb program right after and it
was in the same part of the country
Roswell is not far from Al mordo and
from uh Los Alamos so what do you make
of this recent Resurgence um give it
what do you make of the testimony and
the in the and and one of my friends is
here tonight a fighter pilot in the US
Navy who I did a podcast with another
fighter pilot who who claims to have
encountered uh certain things or have
eyewitness reports about that what do
you make of all this is it important is
it just fun tellman said and I've always
subscribed to this he said I think you
know UFOs are aliens UFOs being ATT
treated to aliens it's kind of amazing
when you think about it so you see
something up in the sky you don't know
what it is it's immediately aliens okay
now let me give two aspects that what
fan said is I think UFOs are more likely
and I the other day I was explaining to
the audience that pH to say more likely
or less likely we don't but UFOs are
much more likely due to the known
irrationality of humans rather than the
unknown rationality of aliens and he
said that because if you think about it
and I guess one of my books I think
Beyond Star Trek I talked about this a
great length almost anything you can
think of regardless of how absurd it may
seem as an explanation of what people
may see out there is more likely than
it's it's aliens
coming here to to to Earth so almost
anything you can think of is more likely
the laws of physics are such the known
laws of physics forget the unknown laws
of physics the known laws of physics put
constraints that make it so unlikely
that anything you could think of it's
like the Magic Bullet in the Kennedy
assassination anything is more likely
than it that it's aliens and I the way I
like to think of it this way to to come
for an alien spaceship powered by Fuel
inside the spaceship to come here from a
distant star at nearest light speed
would require harnessing essentially the
power output of a star I have a hard
time thinking they come all the way here
to abduct patients of some Harvard
psychiatrist and do kinky experiments on
them I mean it just seems like a big
waste of time to me so it's almost 8
o'clock um yeah let me ask you one
question it's almost 8 o'clock we should
end I do want to ask you one question an
experimental question because you got to
ask me a bunch here but I did want to
say what experimentally in and it gives
you a chance to maybe talk about your
own work too but what experimentally do
you think is the ne what technology is
going to be most useful in in your area
physics or in physics in general that
you're aware of yeah so you know I'm a
experimental cosmologist which means I
build universes in the labor no I don't
build universes we build telescopes that
have technology to do it like Galileo
did with the telescope to reveal things
deeper and farther and more exotic than
what we could perceive close to home and
the project that I'm privileged to be
leading is called the Simon Observatory
which is a100 million plus experiment in
high Atacama Desert of Chile where we
are going to attempt to be the first
instrument to do something that's never
been done before which is to measure the
actual spark that ignited the big bang
and it shares some properties in common
with dark energy uh that Lawrence
mentioned earlier but it could provide a
whole host of cosmic observables that
would answer a lot of question s that
cosmologists and late people have had
and one of my philosophies as a as a as
an adviser to my students is reach you
know reach for the stars as Casey KAS
said but keep your feet on the ground
and and that to me means uh do something
really ambitious like measure what
actually banged who banged she bang no
no I don't know if she bang uh but but
let's keep it you know yeah we'll keep
it
clean famous pops on uh but the question
is is there something safe that you also
get get no matter what and for us that's
measuring the mass of these ghostly
particles called ninos that we've known
about for 100 years this is neat but I
would like you but what I really would
like you to do because is these are now
people say this is great but why don't
you say how you're going to do it I
think that's that's really NE because
you know what techn I you know I know
but I think it's worth explaining what
you're what the Simon's Observatory so
I'll do I'll do a little demo here so I
brought a handy dandy flashlight which
you can hope see in the back I won't
blind you it has a blinding mode which
is kind of cool if Lawrence gets out of
hand I'll BL oh sorry I didn't mean to
blasting so if you have a light source
you can use that light source to
illuminate everything not only about
where the light source itself was
created but everything it encounters
along the way here it's my finger or
here it's this uh vodka Coke no no it's
just plain Coke um and and so you can
learn about it by knowing something
about the source of life and it's in its
primitive State and then how it has been
transformed by the medium the material
along its path if you can detect it so
we build the most sensitive detectors
ever made I can see literally this
flashlight on the moon and in
appropriate units uh from here in on the
planet Earth we don't have a launch a
satellite it's not like the web
telescope it's much much less expensive
look pretty expensive and we cool down
these Ultra sensitive detectors instead
of your eye Galileo's eye looking
through a telescope we look through
telescopes with very very sensitive
highly sophisticated Quantum devices
called superconductor bomet and we build
those here in San Diego we shipped them
down to Chile they just took their first
astronomical image of the Moon and if
you saw it you'd be hardly impressed
because it just looks like almost like a
like a bell curve and that's about it
but that's the first wispy indications
that we are on the right track to
actually unveil both the properties of
the extremely early universe and then
the late Universe neutrinos exotic
particles forces Fields energy and
matter and what's really fun is we get
paid to really not to prove people like
Lauren right but to actually prove
everybody else wrong perhaps and then
the last woman or man standing that
theory is the one that for a provisional
period of time is entitled to enjoy some
attention until some other Theory comes
along and experiment to supplant it so
it's to me it's the most exciting time
to be there's many other telescopes if
Rubin Nancy Grace observatories these
are space and ground as a theorist I I
mean and this would happen as I say well
after I graduated but the other thing
that's worth important saying to the
students and everyone else too is I I
certainly learned a lot more physics
after I got my PhD than I did before and
I learned a lot about experimental
physics because to me it fascinates me
and I
remember before you were even a student
at case uh talking about the importance
of bomet and and we proposed Bomer to
look for dark matter and it was amazing
to me to see what you could do with you
know superc conducting technology and
bomet but by the same token that's why
I'm a theorist because that was 40 years
ago yeah and then all the experiments
have to work for 40 years and I just
have to write the paper in 1985 and I
can do go do something else so thank you
Lauren thanks for watching part one of
my very special conversation with
Lawrence Krauss after our conversation
concluded at the San Diego Air and Space
Museum we did a wonderful Q&A session
with the H hundred or so members of the
audience but to get access to that
you'll need to subscribe to my mailing
list at bring.com you'll also be
eligible to enter a drawing to win a
real piece of 4 billion year old space
Schmutz a meteorite a real piece of our
early solar systems history and if you
have an edu email address you
automatically win so to get one if you
have an edu address go to bring.com edu
and enter your email to win a real chunk
of our early solar system looking
forward to seeing you in the Q&A session